i want to welcome everyone
um to this session of endeavors which is
the department colloquium for african
american studies here at yale university
um i'm jacqueline goldsby i'm chair of
the department
and on behalf of our faculty our
graduate students our undergraduate
students and staff i want to welcome
everyone here it's exciting to see
faces and names that i don't recognize
and that's exactly the kind of outreach
we
want to accomplish with this series
um since i want to say a couple things
about the series itself
what it is what's on deck for us this
this semester the remainder of the
semester
and a couple of uh reminders about zoom
etiquette
um how we're going to be running um this
particular session
um i'll start that now by saying as you
all are
now probably your mics are muted and
we'd ask you to keep your mics muted
throughout
the the discussion today um it's okay
as some of you are doing to keep your
videos turned off
zoom fatigue is real um and
the important thing is to be engaged
with your mind and your thinking
and um which leads to the the third zoom
etiquette point
um that we will be using the chat very
actively
during this session um that will be the
conduit and our
um other host today professor crystal
feemster will explain this in a little
bit more detail but i just want to say
now
that we'll be using the uh the chat
function to talk with one another
um you can post ideas thoughts questions
reflections
if you want to pose a question directly
to our speaker today
you would send that question or query
that comment to professor feenster
through the chat but those are some of
the ground rules for
our discussion today but again
endeavors is the department colloquium
for african american studies and for
those of you who are with us for the
first time
um it's there are two hallmarks to our
colloquium
first of all we all gather together um
because instead of separating out our
colloquium according to subfields
we understand our work in black studies
to be interdisciplinary
so we deliberately have one forum
where we bring together leading critics
scholars artists activists to present
work in progress work that they are
doing right now
so that when they come together and
think with us we can help them
sharpen their ideas their practice their
their uh the projects that they're
engaged in and we in turn can bring
their methods their questions their
energy to the work we're doing
um in our own respective fields so
two hallmarks about this uh um this
colloquium
it's about work happening now and it's
in progress and it's about
interdisciplinarity
this semester the theme of our
colloquium
um typically we allow ourselves to kind
of range across
the field of black studies and to invite
who's ever doing the most exciting work
that we want to think with um but given
the existences that we face
right now the ways in which we are rake
reckoning right this is the term
with all of the ways in which race has
made and unmade
the modern world and the particular
fates of black people within it
we are deciding to focus our attention
on what it means to be black now
and to think about and to hold
conversations towards the change the
revolution
that needs to happen um in so many
different areas of life
of one of which will take place in two
weeks on november third with the
election
and so we've organized a whole series of
conversations to think about those
pressing
areas where scholarship and action come
together
um for those of you who were with us
last month we started off with natasha
brown
talking who's a voting rights activist
and her work with black voters matters
is
absolutely pivotal for the moment we're
in
and the ways in which she actually
offered us a new theory of thinking
about
electoral participation and
doing that work she was literally trans
uh
holding her conversation with us on a
bus traveling through north carolina
going to another voter registration
event was absolutely scintillating
and we'll soon have that um discussion
posted online for you to
listen to and think with um today we're
going to be focusing on the politics of
mass incarceration and health justice
with our guests of physician activist dr
emily wang
who professor thiemsen will introduce in
just a moment
and i just want to call attention to the
fact that we have three more events
lined up for the rest of the semester um
you can
register for these events on our
department's website
um these events will be held on november
9th
november 19th and december 10th
where we will be continuing these
discussions around for instance the role
of art
as protest how art pleads freedom
um with the painter acted as titus
kaffar
and with the poet lord lawyer i want to
say laureate but
you know he's a lawyer reginald dwayne
betts
we will have two sessions on the
politics of policing with our new
colleague
social psychologist philip ativa goff
through his work for the center for
policing equity
that will be on november 19th and then
on december 10th
another of our new colleagues elizabeth
henton who's a historian
and one of our long time allies in the
law school uh
tracy mears will be talking about the
work that's happening
at the yale law school's justice
collaboratory so invite everybody
who's here today to sign up for those
events you can go to our department
website
and register for those zoom links
i want to take a couple more minutes
here to thank the collaboratory so to
speak
that's organized and running this series
um
our principal co-sponsor is the center
for the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration
and its director stephen pitty professor
stephen pitty and
the assistant director matthew taniko
have been absolutely indispensable
in helping us to organize and to mount
this series and i really want to thank
them
for their collaboration and their
support um i want to
thank um the african american studies
department senior administrative
assistant vanessa epps
who's done a tremendous job working with
professor crystal themester
getting the word out getting the series
organized
thank you so much vanessa i also want to
thank our tech support
um emmanuel bissell i hope i'm
pronouncing your name correctly emanuel
um he's keeping this he's keeping this
room
up and going so thank you so much
emmanuel
and finally i want to thank our chief
curator
of this series professor crystal
feemster
now i can let it go without saying how
amazing
and brilliant and wonderful professor
femster is
because many of us here have the
opportunity and the honor
of working with her every day
taking classes with her maybe three
times a week um
but we have the chance to work with her
every day but for those of you who don't
know her i just want to make clear
that professor feemster is one of the
nation's leading
historians of the u.s south and a black
feminist history
her award-winning book seven horrors
transformed
how we understand
post-reconstruction-era racial violence
by excavating the under-known histories
of rape as a tool of racial domination
along with lynching
in those decisive eras and she's
increasing the magnifying power of that
analysis
in her next books she's writing two of
them that examine the
uses of sexual violence in the u.s civil
war these are going to be game-changing
books
and we're very lucky to have her
bringing that intellectual power to
organizing
this series i want to thank her for her
work and with that
i'll turn it over to her to introduce
our guest today
um thank you jackie professor goldsby
for that lovely introduction um and also
thank you for you know making sure that
endeavors continued um this term
under all of the stress and
circumstances that we're all facing
um you know you were the one who said
we've got to have these conversations
and we in the department and those
in the yale community were more than
willing
to say yes to these conversations um and
for all of us to kind of do this work
and be in this space together
in these difficult times is really
important so thank you for
insisting on that and leading us and
having these conversations
i also want to thank vanessa um i just
want to add um
to to your um your note of gratitude
um that vanessa has sort of come in new
to fam
and really rallied um and supported me
in this
this series so thank you vanessa
um and emmanuel as well um
nothing but gratitude um for making this
happen
it wouldn't be happening without the two
of you so thank you
um i also want to thank in advance
rachel my racial formation folks
just um because i'm putting you on the
spot i know you're here
um this is part of like your first year
induction into african-american studies
and
we're glad you're here we want to see
you here we want to hear your voice and
i'm hoping that you're going to help me
amplify some of the things that
professor wang is going to share with us
so when you hear her saying something
that you think needs to be repeated or
needs to be highlighted
i want you to hit that up in the chat um
and i will repeat some of the things
that she says and i'll ask questions and
have her go back over some things
for us because this is a moment for us
to really learn
um from dr wang um and so
you know let's make sure that we
highlight what's important here
and on that note what's important is
what
um professor wang is going to offer up
to us today and i want to get that
conversation going and
first i want to introduce um professor
wang or dr wang
so i have to say i i actually have been
sort of i don't want to say stalking but
following dr wang for a while now
on both the professional and the
personal front
um full disclosure she lives in my
neighborhood
and she's got three daughters who are
the same age as my youngest theo
and they were in the kindergarten class
so i was like who's this person who's
got triplets um
how is she doing this and then when i
found out that who she was i said oh my
god
she's amazing um and i also
sort of first came across you through
your efforts
to ban the box your work around that and
i really was it was
one of those issues that i had never
thought of and
i remember when you sent me an email
about it i was just like who is this
person
what is this issue um and so i have kind
of tracked you and followed you
and i'm so excited that um
i get to introduce you to this community
um both that's like an amazing community
person in my neighborhood but also as an
amazing scholar
so um dr wayne wang is an associate
professor
in the yale school of medicine and
directs the new
um center for health and justice called
sheesh
i think i got it right but she will
correct me if i didn't i'm sure of it
um the center for um
health and justice is a collaborative
between yale school
of medicine and yale law school working
to stimulate community
transformation identify the legal pop
legal policy and practice levers that
can improve the health of individuals
and communities impacted by mass
incarceration
she also heads the health justice lab
that does
which is a research program which
receives national institutes of health
funding
to investigate how incarceration
influences chronic health conditions
including cardiovascular disease cancer
and opioid use disorder and uses
and uses a participatory approach to
studying interventions
which mitigate the impact of
incarceration
and i want to just sort of hit that
again that she uses a participatory
approach and i think for those of you
who are coming out of my
civil rights course i think this is
something i want you to kind of pay
attention to
and i want you to think about some of
the people that we've been talking about
ella baker and participatory democracy
and see what professor wang is going to
tell us about that
um and finally she's an internist and
she's cared for thousands of individuals
with a history of incarceration and is
the co-founder of the transitions clinic
network
a consortium of 40 community health
centers nationwide
dedicated to caring for individuals
recently released from correctional
facilities
by employing community health workers
with histories of incarceration
and i'm going to leave it there there's
a lot more i could say
it is on our flyer and she does have an
amazing website that you can go to
that links to many of her articles that
she's published on a range of topics
um and hopefully we'll get to cover some
of them but i know that we're not going
to be able to cover everything
that she has her hands in um but do
check out her website um and the
articles that she's published and on
that note
i'm going to turn it over to emily to
really introduce us to herself
and her work and what the new center is
going to be doing and how it builds on
the work
that she's already been doing so welcome
emily and thank you
thank you you know it's just a a
deep honor um to be here i i have to say
it's one of these things when you're
looking through your calendar and i
really
you know i'm like probably minute to
minute now but
at times week to week i just was so
excited
to be here it's always joyful to be in
conversation with crystal and in
particular
for something entitled conversations for
the revolution
sign me up and so you know i think
one of the things that i'll start with
today is that um
you know it i think it's critical
there's not a lot of physicians like
there's
not a lot of spaces within the schools
of medicine where physicians are talking
about the revolution
and yet i think it's critical to have
uh physicians um and health systems
really
actively engaged in this and you know in
my world what this is
in increasingly especially with young
students
younger students residents uh kind of
more
junior faculty is talking about the
abolition of the police state
elaboration of the cultural state
um and the reality that i present which
is that
those are all yes and true um but i've
had the opportunity as a practicing
physician as crystal has indicated
um that you know if you look at examples
right now of
closing rikers you know and if you talk
to physicians that are practicing within
rikers
you know and they've had historic drops
in the jail population that we could go
into now so historic
just with you know stupid
idiot easy changes that should have long
happened but haven't and then they
finally did
you can get the population down from
thirteen thousand to eleven thousand to
now you know it's
five thousand but at the very end of the
days there's probably about thousands
people
that won't be able to go home there's no
place to go home there's no health
system to care for them there's no place
for them to live
our communities have entirely abrogated
their responsibilities
at the community health systems the
housing systems etc
to those individuals and so in thinking
about kind of
um dismantling a cultural state and
thinking about kind of what abolition
looks like
it requires a real deep reconstruction
a real reckoning with the with the
social structures that do exist what
does our social contract look like
it's so fractured now that we can't
actually provide
for that space that we can't talk about
kind of issues of revolution and
abolition
without saying that then you need an all
hands on deck
approach and folks like me within the
health system have to be on board
and so it's in that space that i sit and
i'm often kind of
in tension which is the practicality
that every friday
steph knows this i see patients that
have just come home from prison and jail
and so it keeps it real because there's
a real reality an individual
with their family sometimes and then
certainly we're turning into the
community where the resources are just
limited
and it's that space that you can think
really and truly
about what revolution looks like it's
going to be a process it's a long call
process
and it needs and requires a
interdisciplinary
intersector intersector approach
to really thinking about how this looks
so i i'll
start then by saying this that um
increasingly in my work
and professor goldsby alluded to this
what i love
most is being in interdisciplinary
spaces
we recently um have a grant now actually
that we'll be looking at covid19 and
i'll touch on this a little bit
within prisons and jails um
and uh have an amazing opportunity also
to look at the history of
mass incarceration um and pandemics and
so
um elizabeth hinton will be partnering
on this we're going to look at looking
at the legal barriers and again that's
tracy mears partnering on this
to me this is where it lies is that if
we do not
have scholars and also people that have
been incarcerated
and also people that are currently
incarcerated
knee deep in the solutions of the past
knee deep in what has worked in the past
and what just didn't get scaled up
and knee deep on what we are presented
with now we're just not going to get
anywhere and so it's that place too that
i really
like to be um all right so
what i thought is usually that this is
zoom land and it's kind of terrible for
me
but usually what i usually do is to say
you know like
try to answer the first questions like
why the hell is a doctor kind of
interested in this stuff
and um for me the place that's easiest
for me to share with you just photos
um of uh prisons and jails and what
health systems look like just to give
you a picture
so i'll do a raise your hand if you've
and i'll just try to quickly flash over
my zoom
if you've stepped foot into a prison or
jail before
okay so a good number and then people
aren't honest
i've got it and then what about have you
been in uh healthcare sitting
settings
okay all right crystal
and amy super so um so this will be
somewhat new to some of you and then
very new to others of you and so
um uh if there's terms and unfortunately
once i share my screen i can't see the
chat
um but maybe i'll ask crystal to stop me
if you feel like i'm throwing out jar
again crystal
okay i will one of the places i'll start
uh is just to share that you know
oftentimes people
have i think the media presents it
poorly which is that
the folks who are incarcerated that's
2.2 million individuals and then we have
a whole system of community supervision
but 2.2 million individuals that are
incarcerated
are this like young healthy lot that's
able to exercise they're doing well
they did a crime they're inside and the
truth is
is that that just isn't the case so you
know the patient demographic and i
frequently use the term patients they're
not all patients but that is just my
lens so i apologize for that
but the patient demographic is changing
um
the population behind bars given the
incredibly long sentences we've had have
meant that there's a disproportionate
proportion
of individuals that are 55 and older and
um it and
you know when the last estimates were
looked at it's about
80 percent of individuals within jails
and prisons that have a chronic
health condition that warrants
longitudinal primary care
so this includes like this patient here
he's got copd
and you know i shared these pictures
just for you to give a look at
what healthcare looks like they're
waiting to see a doctor so there's one
patient here that's getting kind of an
albuterol like a treatment
to help open his lungs next to another
patient
who has a mental illness and he's in a
cage so this is how health care
is structured behind bars and so
when i say that about 80 have a chronic
health condition so for a range
of uh what i mean is a range of
conditions so
you know high blood pressure asthma copd
like this guy has
to also hepatitis c infectious diseases
like
hiv and hepatitis c to also depression
post-traumatic stress disorder
schizophrenia opioids disorder all those
conditions require you know i'd say
most physicians would say a primary care
doctor and so
while you know we have the impressions
that folks are generally healthy in fact
they aren't and they're aging behind
bars in systems that were never
designed to actually provide the
healthcare for chronic health conditions
um emily yeah i'm curious
you know i'm thinking about a few years
ago
there were black women in alabama
two sisters i think who had like kidney
failure i don't remember if you remember
this story
but it seems to me that there was a
moment and i don't know if it's still
the case
that around sort of d um incarceration
that was
linked to the the economics
of health care right that in some of
these states
um you know the republicans and more
conservative people were willing to kind
of think about
um decarceration and reducing the number
of
people who are incarcerated because of
health
expenses and the sort of cost of health
care is is that is that something that
is has
happened or is happening yeah
but that's a really important point so
yes it is that you know
i've been doing this for over a decade
and and i'd say right now we're at a
place of
increasing bipartisan support that kind
of whatever you call this
you know that the cultural state mass
incarceration has been a failed policy
it hasn't changed
uh violent crime rates and also costs us
too much so
you'll see more right-leaning folks are
just blatantly right folks you know
saying
there's a whole right on crime right um
that it's the costs of incarceration
that are what are driving uh uh is their
animus for
trying to decarcerate our country but
there is consensus
that the prison and jail population is
too big
and in large part these costs are driven
by health care costs
exactly as you're pointing out the aging
you know your two sisters with end-stage
renal disease they cost and they cost
more in corrections than they would in
the community
right okay thank you
um and then you know of course and
especially thinking about covid which we
could talk about a little bit because
maybe that's my work in progress right
now that we can touch on
that prison environments can of course
exacerbate poor health and i just want
you to think about the world in which
we're living right now
right we're masked socially distanced
and think about
these uh individuals right here so
all these pictures i should say come
from california department of
corrections
i actually uh did my residency training
in san francisco
and had a longitudinal primary care
clinic within this prison in san quentin
and so
um you know these pictures come from
them and
you know i just use it to highlight that
it's incredibly overcrowded again our
policies of mass incarceration have led
to situations like this
where people are triple bunking in
gymnasiums and then of course in these
circumstances
are hotbeds for covid19 you know we can
go into that for forever but you can
only imagine how you just can't socially
distance in places like this
but also places where because of the
stress rates of cardiovascular disease
we're hypothesizing
are are increasing so you know there's a
lot of work thinking about kind of toxic
stress and what this looks like and
amped up um stress responses
um and in particular uh what that means
for
short-term health but also long-term
health what that means for mental health
but also physical health and so
the actual environments the built
environment but also the ways that
prisons and jails are defined
really kind of can magnify different
conditions and health
and so what drew me to this is as
follows so
this blew my mind like i i don't think i
would have ever been
you know like i was a primary care
doctor thinking about medicine and
i wouldn't have seen you know you asked
me 20 years ago would this be kind of
the focus of what i did
it wouldn't have been um but
prior to the affordable care act prisons
and jails are
one of the only places in the u.s where
health care is constitutionally
guaranteed
and so what this meant uh for me i mean
it it kind of is inconceivable but
you'll see why this matters a lot
there's a court case
in 1976 a stealthy gamble that kind of
created the constitutional rights to
health care
behind bars is that if you think about a
population this 2.2 million people that
are incarcerated
who are disproportionately black latino
you know and
a racial and ethnic background of low
income
oftentimes prisons and jails are the
first place
where individuals access healthcare as
adults
this is where they learn this is where
they experience this is where they meet
their first doctor
this is where they understand their
chronic conditions and so this has
significant bearing
for their kind of relationship with the
health care system
their trust of the system you can
imagine now in kova 19 their trust in
kind of participating in
any sort of issue that is tied to kind
of health healthcare healthcare system
design and to me it also speaks to this
which is that it has been a place as
you'll hear me go through
a place where people are first accessing
preventive health measures
actually do get treated for the first
time for hepatitis c in circumstances
and so
um it's a conflicted place partially i
think because we do such a terrible job
in the community
and because we house so many black and
brown people inside
that there is this perverse kind of um
experience of
health care that starts in prisons and
jails and then gets transitioned home
so if you look at our data and others
about 40 of individuals that are
incarcerated are newly diagnosed with
the chronic condition while they're
incarcerated
and um emily so
you know since so many um young
black and brown folks are having for the
first time interacting with doctors i'm
curious if you could speak to
who are the doctors what kind of doctors
are
are doing this kind of um service like
who are the doctors i you know i
actually think crystal it's like a mixed
bag so in the news you're gonna hear
it's like
um you know the problematic stories
right so people that are not boarded in
their specialty oftentimes it's like
you know misbehaving physicians or
criminal physicians frankly that have
lost licensure then moved to a different
state and have started a practice within
a correctional system and doing stuff
out of licensure
and also i would say that there are also
physicians that commit to it because
they're kind of interested in taking
care
of patients that are more vulnerable
really trying to think about this as
it then i said that's the younger
generation of physicians that are more
embracing of kind of a more social
justice
uh vision but it's a mixed bag i i also
think you're going to a place where you
know if you think about community health
systems i mean
there is an infrastructure that protects
you so
you crystal when you go to the hospital
and you're seeing a doctor yell new
haven hospital
um you can rest assured that there are
certain kind of
approvals that have to be taken on in
order for
that hospital to get financed these are
national guidelines of a certain quality
of care that has to be delivered in the
health system otherwise they don't get
the funding from medicaid medicare
and private insurers okay so you can be
certain of it
there is no federal or state mandatory
oversight of health care behind bars
period none and so again
you know there's a heterogeneity so i
don't want to impugn you know colleagues
of mine that work inside doing the good
work
and also you just don't know what the
work is
right like you we have no way of knowing
so when you go
into your new haven hospital you can
rest assured that it's been approved by
jayco
when you go in here there's just no way
of knowing and
this is inherently the issue which is
that there's no transparency there's no
kind of
our taxpayer cash pays for the care
that's delivered in connecticut
department of corrections and you have
no
idea of knowing if they're meeting the
standard metrics for quality
nor do you know about the quality of
physicians all right okay
thank you um
and so you know i just highlight this
and maybe this um
photo is is better for kind of
physicians and training or health um
you know students in the health ally
professionals but you know again
while there is this constitutional
access to care it's just
totally entirely different and so this
was a patient that
i had met he had just been diagnosed
with like um a condition where your
blood pressure is out of control it's so
crazy that you might be at risk for
stroke it's called hypertensive
emergency so he's sent out to the
outside hospital so that we have to
contract out of course because most
prisons don't have their own hospital
comes back in and this is supposed to be
the place where he recuperates
okay so you know just to start i mean
just look
around i'm rounding as a physician
and everyone in earshot correction
officer is there there's the person
right next to him
you know incarcerated as well as
listening you throw the cuff through
many of you probably have gone to a
doctor where they check a blood pressure
this is not properly positioned he has
to place it on himself and you're kind
of having a deal conversation with him
trying to like see like
when did you learn if you're the doctor
in there and i was like
of course there's drugs in there and you
want to kind of talk to them about
things that doctors would talk about and
you're not able to
um the other thing to just note is that
you know um
this patient will never have to call a
pharmacy to get his meds
never even have to give himself a
reminder like the whole kind of how he
manages his chronic condition for those
of you are on blood pressure pills
what happens is that every morning he's
called to the crack of dawn
correctional officer wakes him up he
goes and makes a line
his cup is filled it's a medline he has
to you know drink it
and then the nurse checks to see if he's
cheeked it
and then come uh and then he makes it
back to his room
and so it's incredibly passive it's
almost
it's totally paternalistic like it's
childlike um
and but adherence is 100 right
if you don't adhere um we've done
studies that have shown this like for
instance let's say you're like i'm not
feeling like getting an insulin
injection today
right um and for whatever reason
folks uh participants have stated
in studies that they've been sent to
solitaire confinement
and so there is this entirely different
notion of how health care is delivered
how it's administered how people see it
and how people are punished for it
within corrections that of course
doesn't translate into the types of
you know doctor patient relationship you
want to create
the other thing too is every time this
doctor this patient wants to see a
doctor so in connecticut for instance
um for a chronic disease visit you have
to pay uh three bucks
so you're like well it's three bucks
right well
three bucks is equivalent to four days
work if you're lucky enough to have a
job
and so again there's just so many
different barriers that exist
for people that are incarcerated to
actually access care
um this picture i highlight so it's just
just pointing out this um
pink slip and so it's a kite that
patients have to fill out
again um when they want to see a a
provider a health care provider doctor
and so
you know again this is no longer
happening in california but it's still
happening all over the country
the person fills it out that then gets
evaluated by a correctional officer
the correctional officer then decides
like whether or not it's a valid medical
concern it goes to a nurse
and then it goes to a physician and so
again
all sorts of barriers um to getting care
this also is an hiv clinic um and so
again there's just no confidentiality i
mean again there's a correctional
officer walking by
everyone in this line knows that they're
all going to see the hiv doctor and so
just the whole notion the kind of values
that we hold true and are principled
and ones around human dignity and rights
are infringed upon and infringed upon
largely a population that is uh of
low-income and racial minorities
that again have rarely accessed the
canadian health system
and then you know i always show this
picture and um
you know for me this is just the deep
brutality the kind of
the violence that the health system can
exert
um on uh individuals and so you know
think about that first patient that i
showed you
you know an older gentleman that you
know maybe is requiring oxygen now and
this happened to be
not the same guy but another patient who
uh
needs chronic oxygen administration for
his uh
copd and you can just note here that
um the oxygen is outside his altair
confinement door
and so you know you would hear him is
when it kinked like
bamming on the door if you know you'd
walk by and doctors would walk by and i
remember being a person in training
being like how's this
permissible and it's because the values
of kind of
safety you know really trump the values
of
of of dignity but for of health right
and so
um there's many many different
expressions of violence that are kind of
just ingrained within the system
and are difficult to of course shake off
when
people come home you know you wonder why
there's all sorts of notions within
medicine about non-compliance and people
that are mistrustful
these people and then you think about
this
and that's life preserving to actually
be mistrustful it's life preserving to
not
kind of trust in health systems it
literally is the smartest and strategic
thing that you can
do
and so you know where my work kind of
sits mostly is
at this intersection i'd say is that the
vast majority
you know jeremy travis said that nearly
95 of individuals come home to the
community and that's about right
that you know for what it is we have 2.2
million in
and 95 folks will actually end up coming
home
and so um i think what is the most
interesting to me
is that it's actually their health
outcomes
you know if you compare what happens
when they're incarcerated versus when
they come home
are significantly worse when people come
home
so you have about a 12 times increased
risk of dying in the first two weeks
post-release big seminal study published
in
you know new england journal medicine
that showed that the first
most common cause of dying is overdose
but then heart disease
and
homicide response governance homicide
suicide and cancer
and then other chronic conditions as
well depending on what states
and data you're looking at it's like
hepatitis c cancers from that
but again a really elevated risk of
dying in those first two weeks post
release
a really elevated risk of
hospitalizations and
not surprisingly a worsening of all
chronic conditions and this is because
we have
just so many barriers to people coming
home right so
inabilities to you know as as crystal
mentioned
you can't find a job because you always
have to check a box you cannot
find a place to live there's a ban on
food stamps you cannot you know like
find a place to live because you you
have a criminal record and you can't
live in public housing or your family
member can't house you because you have
a criminal record and it just goes on
and on and so
the real challenge for us as a health
system is figuring out
how better to engage people who come
home
and so one of the things that crystal
alludes to and i won't go into it
much now um but it's just that we
using participatory approaches about now
15 years ago
started a transitions clinic program in
san francisco it's where i trained
and really uh deeply in partnership with
people that had been
previously incarcerated there's a long
civil rights movement that's embedded
uh there that we partnered with all of
us are none um
and uh um and uh
really created a program that uh i think
was centered around the values
preferences and needs of people with
history's incarceration
and core among that and here's the
picture here on the right
who's our first community health worker
have community health workers that are
embedded within primary care clinics
that have histories incarceration
themselves
um and really um i think
part of what i've found in doing this
work you know i personally haven't been
incarcerated
um but yeah there's when we started this
program i'll say now we have like 45
programs
across the country there's so many deep
naysayers like our whole science our
whole notions
especially within health systems is one
about mitigating risk like all this
stuff is wrong
in these people and we just have to make
them more normal right
that there isn't a lot of value and what
we're really trying to do
as a as a community you know within
transitions
is to change that narrative is there's
so much going right
you know there are lots of people
and uh assets within communities that
have been impacted by mass incarceration
and that too
should inform our science and so you
know through the years what we've been
able to do is you know
using kind of the best of of of empiric
design using randomized control trials
show that in transitions clinic programs
actually does improve
health care utilization improves primary
care it actually reduces
future criminal justice contact and so
really trying to shift
the entire narrative which is that there
is value
in also looking at what functions well
in these communities
and also them studying that to scale
the second thing i'd say is that um i'm
just moving through these
pictures a little bit more is that in
seeing these patients over time one of
the things i've realized is
there's just not a lot that's known
about this population the science is
terrible
and um i share with you this figure from
a paper that
we wrote um and uh i won't
how are we doing on time i see oh not
good crystal
we're doing we're doing great on time i
mean okay this information
is really important so i want you to
share it with us and we
we we go to 4 30. okay
go like tamp me down um so
um i i just share with you this because
i do think it's something that's lost
on um yeah
you know it's something i guess i've
come to to see over time so you know i
have patients that'll ask me like well
what do you think doc
is the best choice for me like what do
the studies show
and so i share with you this study that
we did so
on the left hand column i mean you guys
probably don't recognize but these are
large
cohort studies so population-based
studies where they follow
thousands sometimes tens of thousands of
individuals in the u.s
that are um really keyed on they're
funded by the nih the national
institutes of health so taxpayer dollars
trying to figure out the core etiology
of heart disease
okay so these are all the big ones like
cardia jackson heart study
mesa enrich i mean you see them all
there okay and so we took
all the studies that followed people for
over two years
okay and um and we're
we're intentionally designed to study
what are black white differences
okay and what we wanted to do was
um in particular to see how much
mass incarceration has impacted the
validity of these studies
okay so we know that you know based on
earlier work there's about a one in
three lifetime risk of a black man
being incarcerated in this country over
his lifetime okay and it's even higher
the the risk is higher in certain
communities but it's one in three
population based over
uh um in this country and so
one of the questions we wanted to know
was how often do these big population
studies
actually go into prisons and jails how
often do they include the folks that are
incarcerated
and then let's say that you recruit
someone
in the community a young healthy black
man and then he gets picked up by the
system do they actually follow them in
and the problem with that is
the follow-up is really important for
these studies because if you don't have
follow-up then you don't have internal
validity you just can't make any
conclusions about black men as a
subcategory in these studies
okay and so um what we found first was
these are the 25 biggest studies
that nhlbi funds how how many of them do
you
how many of them crystal do you think
looked at
uh incarcerated individuals um
i'm putting you on the spot now no no
you can um
what let's say 10 of them maybe
get them all right zero none
not a one okay one of them cardia
asks one question it's been following
people for 30 years i mean
all the stuff that we know about heart
disease in young folks comes from
cardiac so anything when any time
like there was a big thing about how
much marijuana impacts your lung
function that's coming from cardiac
anything that has to do with kind of
cardiovascular
and pulmonary health from an hlbi comes
from these studies
so zero go into prisons and jails
one asks the question and then
none of them follow people into prisons
and jails either
zero okay so then we just try to
estimate how much the loss to follow up
in these studies of black men
might be attributable to incarceration
because we couldn't actually measure it
and it turns out it's a good bit so
ranging you know from fifteen percent
the lowest all hats probably the lowest
at five percent to cardia
all the way up uh in black men to twenty
five percent
right so at uh twenty five percent of
the estimated loss to follow follow-up
i'm actually not reporting this well so
red is the actual loss to follow up and
this is how much of the loss to
follow-up can be attributed to
incarceration so in this study it looks
like it's about 60 percent of the loss
development black men
and so it's just a good amount it's a
significant amount in some studies and
what it speaks to me is just that
that's a picture a sketch of one of my
patients that he always loves me to
share it's mark baskerville um is that
for this patient here's mark
we just don't know what much about his
health like it when it comes down to it
we don't know much about the health of
young black men
we don't know much about the health of
men that and women but
in particular men that pass through
prisons and jails
and it's a huge hole in our knowledge
and so what we've done is just within
our
lab is really try to change that and try
to
focus our questions squarely on changing
the narrative around those who are
incarcerated and changing the questions
that are asked
um and so uh you know one of the things
i'm
most proud of is that we've pushed
ourselves to really diversify
who's here in our in our lab you know
faculty on through students um have been
directly impacted we really
uh you know this is why i know so much
about yale hiring policy and why then we
work to ban the box because i'm always
that person that's trying to hire a
person with a criminal record
into yale and so i've really gotten to
know the you know general counsel well
um and so the majority of our our lab
has either been incarcerated or has a
family member or multiple family members
that are
currently incarcerated and we're focused
on preventing exposure incarceration
mitigating the harms and then improving
health and well-being and really
we'll only focus on interventions that
look at
positive assets and mostly because those
are the questions that our lab members
are interested in so
you know not surprisingly they're like
we're sick of these studies
if we have to see another study that
pathologizes black people we
we won't stomach it and so you know the
place i'd say is for
the um it's been the most growing
uh of the work that i've done it's what
keeps
us all honest us all engaged
in the more complicated questions uh you
know that
enables kind of more rich dialogue about
what needs to happen
and how it needs to happen it's not a
space that i necessarily demure
all my experience you know but it is a
space that where there is
kind of more richness in the sorts of
questions we ask
and uh then how we approach these
questions and so
you know we also made a commitment about
five years ago just to try to get a big
grant in all
major uh causes of death and so have
i'm happy to talk about these more but
you know trials or epi studies going on
at like crystal you alluded to in these
big domains
and then the last thing is that we
recently got awarded a
large grant looking at covet 19 and the
prisons and jails and as i mentioned to
you
um it also um
will have an aim of it that's really
focused on looking at the history of
pandemics
um and you know i kind of switch and end
with this which is that
um i had the opportunity to just
finished this week
um yeah to co-chair a consensus report
for the national academies of science at
engineering medicine
of thinking about what incarceration
looks like um
during covet 19 in particular and you
know we're in a profound place where
again
90 out of the 10 100 largest
outbreaks cluster outbreaks of covet
happened in prisons and jails up until
the colleges started opening and
now that it's being taken over by
colleges um but prior to that it was in
prisons and jails and incarceration
depopulation
is a big piece of uh a tool
that can be used to mitigate uh cova
transmission we've done some research
that
there's been a few other studies and but
our team has done that and
it's in that consensus report
um that one of the primary
recommendations is focused on healthcare
and healthcare delivery you know that
in order for us to decarcerate in order
for us to have
a a safe community you know and i mean
that in that kind of
broadest maybe criminologist sense like
a public safety that we have to expand
our notions of what safety
looks like and feels like and
that has to include notions of health
and well-being for people that are
incarcerated as well as the families and
communities to which they return and so
i do think we're in this profound moment
and
you know i haven't been doing this for
that long but at least more than a
decade that
you know who was willing to have this
conversation with me
has changed a lot and i'm grateful for
it
it's people that are surprising
um at least open to conversations about
how health systems
physicians uh are part of uh
um well i'll stop there a revolution you
know and so
um i just appreciate the time that y'all
gave me to
go through these slides and pictures
because i do think
um what it does do is that we've created
you know um say like a third tier health
system that's out
out of you entirely out of view
it impacts so many so
many people their families and
communities
um and creates kinds i mean it's
no wonder you know that of course uh
people are mistrustful of the health
system look at this
you know and so it's incumbent among us
to look internally and and deal with our
own stuff which is what i feel like we
have to do as physicians but also
welcome opportunities to collaborate
across
especially yale where there's just the
richness
of scholars really that can kind of
inform this work is
is mind-blowing so thank you
no thank you emily that was really um
wonderful and i
will start taking um questions in the
chat
as well but i do have a few and there
were some that actually came into the
chat already
um and so i will i will pitch some of
those as well
i know you're um you're going to stop my
screen chair
i have a couple of questions and um to
get us started but i'm i'm hoping we
could start with
um this idea of community-based
participatory research
because it seems like it really is the
center and the heart of what you're
working on and what you're doing
and i'm wondering if you could talk a
little bit about the principles
of that and if you could also talk a
little bit about
how your work and what you're doing is
impacting the new haven community yeah
yeah great so um you know um
there is a long rich tradition
of you know i'd say like
participatory scholarship in that
sentence
within the health sciences it mostly
emerges when i think about it through
barbara israel's work in university of
michigan and so you know like the
expansion of it
and and i would say like again this is
just rooting it
in the u.s within academic structures
which is a wrong routing
like that's that's flawed but you know
in terms of scholarship that's
um looked upon it's it's um it is
barbara israel's work and it's within
university michigan
and core to that just to distill it i
would say
is this that
you will never come to solutions
of health if you don't engage those that
are most involved
period end and in doing so
there's a long range so you know you'll
see a lot of work i think in medicine i
think all of us can kind of
you know as as um as scholars
will look through the literature and be
like oh you know people labeling this
community engage or participatory
so there's a scale is how i think about
it and at its most
core you know fundamental if you're
thinking about community-based
participatory research how it's kind of
fully actualized
the question comes from the community
itself
right and it's literally and then with
the question coming from
the community itself it's in partnership
an academic community partnership
that then one is a transfer of resources
and i mean by that
cash resources one two
a trading of knowledge and skill so
that's more participatory right but
again that
transfer has to come from academics to
the community
right three it's partnership throughout
the process it's negotiated throughout
the process
it's discussed throughout the process
but it means in the first articulation
the question that comes from the
community
then you find up the research question
then you figure out the methods and
protocol then you're actually
implementing it then you're analyzing it
and that's a place where there's a lot
of kind of
you know like how many communities
actually have a statistician how many
you know what i mean like really to get
to it so that's a place where there's
deep in equities and same with the cache
and then the last is disseminating it
but in its
fullest articulation it is full
participation through the range
and i have to say it's not easy to do so
that's the first i'm going to say
i will say um partially because the
structures don't
permit it so funding structures
and also kind of deep inequities of like
kind of who can manage and contractual
obligations
we have tried to literally you know like
yeah there's participatory budgeting
kind of i think you know ours is a
really well-funded nih
lab and um have worked
and do participatory budget we're really
transparent around it and what that
means is talking about really gross
stuff which is
how much indirect yale takes off of
grants how little communities will get
how much you know how to support and
build that infrastructure within
community organizations that they can
even take an indirect
right and and that's where it has to go
in the deepest articulation
and also that's really complicated we
had one grant that we were like let's go
50
50. we're gonna give you 2.5 million
we'll take the other 2.5 million
that means that all faculty salaries are
going to be you know squished but we'll
do it
and there's no community organization
within new haven that could take it it's
too much work to take on a real kind of
like
you know uh grassroots organization
doesn't have the accounting
infrastructure to do that and so what
that requires
are the infrastructures within yale to
do that so we have a new office of
health equity research with the new dean
and a good friend of mine uh marcelo
nunez smith i'm sure you all know her
um and that's finally
finally we're going to start trying to
build the infrastructure but it takes
kind of that to be able to do it that's
one and then the second i would say is
that it's deeply enriching of the
science i can't tell you the number of
times where you're like my god we're an
idiot we are asking all sorts of the
wrong questions or if we've gone for
that standard validated measures it
would never have rolled out
and so it's the place where people think
oh that's really nice or oh
emily's that left-leaning it's what
makes
the scientist science more accurate more
externally valid and internally valid so
i really
push back on notions that this is some
kind of like left
leaning progressive you know ways of
including that's crap
this is about the science and it's about
doing this right and it's about shifting
power
and also it's about making sure that
what it is that you discover
together actually is sustained beyond
and so
that's in the fullest articulation i'll
just say this crystal like
not everything should always be
participatory frankly i i think
there are places and spaces to do so and
my lab will be the first to say
it's not easy work right so there's
stuff that we just have to get done
and it's participatory here kind of but
there's we all have our different
expertise and we're okay with that so
that's the second thing i'll say and
then the work that we're doing in new
haven
so clinically within the sage center you
know our our grounding is our clinical
work like that informs everything
because otherwise you can't keep
yourself very real
even with lab members um but
within and so new haven we have a kind
of a transitions clinic network
of um of um
you know there's 45 programs across the
country but there's three sites in
connecticut
and um the research that we have
is uh mostly embedded within connecticut
it's where we have the strongest
relationships where the assets are the
greatest
and so you know i'll just point out kind
of um the
participatory project that we have going
and i'm looking at staff who's been
involved
uh since uh really early on
um at least the nih grant so we've had a
nine year partnership a community
academic partnership
um that's been focused on gun violence
and in particular thinking about
community-led interventions that can
mitigate and
ultimately prevent the community impacts
of gun violence
we were awarded nih funding in that
brief period where they had kind of
an rfa focused on gun violence and what
we've been able to do is apply kind of a
social network analysis so there was a
sociologist here that used to be here
andrew papa cristos
that had a social network analysis and
did that using arrest data
and we tried to incorporate health
system data into the social networks
of um gun violence and
uh we took his data and what we were
really interested like i said
earlier is a positive deviance model so
you know all sorts of folks are focused
on those high risk
people who we're interested in are the
people that actually
are looking like they're high risk and
never get shot
what are they doing right what's helping
them the space is in the community
there's
lots of places that look like they
should have had a ton of shootings
and they didn't statistically right
what's going on right
and so we use that social network
analysis and this is
all in partnership i'm telling you we've
gone nine years with and this is the
group that we're trying to give out the
cash and they couldn't do it so they're
like
oh my god another brand i'm like come on
where can they
so um they did qualitative interviews of
either individuals or those places
where things are working you know or the
places where nothing's happening
and steph led a lot of that work
and then now are using both uh
quantitative data from new haven the
interviews
and using this thing called systems
dynamic modeling so
it's kind of newer in in medicine not a
lot of folks are using but
it's a way of of building a model a
computer simulated model
where you create inputs that give where
you put in local
data okay and then can
simulate um and dialing up and dialing
down
um different factors that might impact
gun violence
so for instance okay and i'll just give
you an example um from a work
uh the process starts with something
called group participatory modeling
where basically this community academic
partnership so you know they've now
gotten all used to the terms
have to really think hard about what are
the different inputs that cause gun
violence
in our community and in particular not
about gun violence but the trauma that
lingers
okay so they create this model and one
of the big things on there let's say is
green spaces
okay and that's been born out in the
literature so of course these folks have
thought about it but there's a good
rich empiric science behind it and then
you put in your model
and what you can do using new haven data
is just say like what if we tweaked up
green spaces in new haven by 20 what
happens to rates of gun violence
what if we and so now the community
members can see this model
use it think about the factors that they
think are important to tweak up and
tweak down
and part of what we're trying to
identify are interventions that could be
community-led entirely
not dependent on government not
dependent on police
that they could lead on their own to
take action to take hold
of something that you know they urgently
need interventions like every government
cycle
and every budget shortfall or whatever
they're done with that
and so um i think we've um
you know it's complicated you know nih
grant cycles are three years or five
years and we're now at a
place where we're coming up with the
intervention um
and it's both exciting but it's also
it it sometimes science is slow it gets
old
right like the rates of gun violence are
going up and i and i tire of it
but i also just remind myself that if we
don't do this well and write
that it i think it's going to be the
same crap like we just don't have
solutions that are actually
with rigorous evidence behind it that
will end up being scaled and then we
end up with more of the same which is
like if we
tile down police dial up police
community-led police like
and it's not to say that those solutions
i mean that's not the conversation i
entertained that's for somebody else our
lab is squarely focused on what works
within communities and helping community
leaders
kind of envision their own safety and
own health
this is amazing emily um and i'm
i'm learning a lot and i want to bring
in a few of the other questions
they range so i'm trying to consolidate
some but there was a question about when
you were talking about health as a
constitutional right
and someone asked explicitly about
mental health
and how that factors in to folks who are
incarcerated
is mental health a part of that
constitutional right and what does it
look like um
in the in the in the prisons yeah so
i don't know the court case but yes it
is part of that constitutional right
and then i will say like healthcare
throughout prisons and jails
there's uh one a real heterogeneity to
that care
and two um we just don't know right
like what we know is that anecdotal
um but what i've seen also over time
you know i've seen really i think like
easily thousands
is that um prisons and jails are
are in and of themselves trauma inducing
and for people that have had either
go into prisons in jails with mental
health disorders
or have had you know significant traumas
and you know
the life course of people that have been
incarcerated is yeah
predominantly um incredibly challenged
incredibly violent
right and then to enter spaces that are
also violent in their kind of
existence right um yeah i think
yeah if if there are solid literature
around kind of the health impacts of
actually being in the cultural system
it's around mental health outcomes and
it's terrible
and so um you know to get into the nitty
gritty i mean what i would say
though is that it is really complicated
i mean um
to make i don't know if i should go in
this tangent but
to make a and to make a uh mental health
diagnosis
and you know i'll just use the example
of psychosis like having kind of a
um and you know i'm an internist so i'll
just say that this is not
you know i think a psychiatrist would
would um
feel like she's not really doing it
justice but
to to i'll just say this is that
oftentimes making the diagnoses within
prisons and different diagnoses in
community
is just very difficult so you know
there's a clear-cut way of diagnosing
high blood pressure right but there
isn't a you know even though there's
guidelines
like a dsm-5 criteria and we go through
it kind of the conditions
of the system inside and you know
oftentimes people
have used an illicit drug while they're
outside really really affect
those diagnoses and so there's just so
much disconnect between these health
systems
a person will be on a mental health you
know drug
treatment engaged in care outside and
then inside
not be seen in the same way you hear
them saying
and vice versa drug treated engaged in
care
come home and they're like we don't see
and so i think it's just like
i can't imagine like i would just be so
frustrated because you're like i was
doing well here and then now i've come
in
and there's nothing and or i was doing
well inside actually and that does
happen like i've just shared with you
guys it's
against it's counter to what we think
but some people's health it's not to say
that we should incarcerate people
but some people's health actually are
managed surprisingly when they actually
have food and a roof over their heads
you know so
it managed better and then come home and
they're just so
aggravated by not having medicaid not
having medicare losing their benefits
they're homeless they you know etc so
that is a really complicated place um
uh in part because of of real breaks and
care in part by
kind of who the providers are how they
see the person and how they see kind of
severity of illness in the certain
circumstances
thank you and um now i have a question
it's
quite very specific around um someone
who's been doing stuff with the
connecticut bell fund hotline
and one of the things that they're
hearing a lot about
is um if we're in prison physicians are
sometimes complicit and
punishing people and withholding
um um care and things like that and
and the person is wondering is there
something that
the lab or the center
is going to do to address some of those
issues that are happening within prisons
um i guess what i would say is that you
know what we do clinically
is is you know if we see a patient in
our clinic and then we see
bad care you know that of course it's
incumbent upon us to then
talk to the provider figure out and um
see what it is that we do within a
research i mean that's not a place that
we're actively investigating and
places that um but i do think it's of
critical importance i mean i
i think oversight is you know as i
indicated there's none
right there's no mandatory oversight i
mean i i it blows my mind
it's we just kind of absolved ourselves
of responsibility we don't want to see
it we don't want to care about it i just
i can't believe that you know um
as a community like this is something we
stand for but it is not a place of
active advocacy right now for um
our center i mean the things that we're
really focused on um
partially because of where we think
we're going to have the most leverage
and maybe this is just strategic
and also just the real deep importance
of decarceration
um is trying to change compassionate
release like trying to
really um shore up the science around it
try to change
the policies it's almost impossible to
get a person to be
uh released in this country and you know
the
the consensus report we just did from
nissan said that you know like one of
the things that
is is clear is that um about 20 the jail
population is
down about 22 percent pre-covered in
postcovid
but the state prison population is down
only four percent
and even in settings where the executive
the governor etc
wanted to release it's just too it's
hard to do like the compassionate
release policies are
too specific too discretionary really
difficult to do
uh to actually see it through and so
um these are the things that we're
working on right now
and i have another question here i'm
going to read it okay
it said it's been striking to me how so
much of the conservative
political discussions around health care
this year with the conservative
politicians and protesters reactions to
mask in the pandemic
and in general regarding conservative
rejections of obamacare
employs the language of force and
incursion on liberty
it's been especially striking this year
against the juxtaposition of
incarcerated and detained individuals
whose health has actually been
threatened by the limitations of their
liberty and mobility
what reconceptualizations of health
public health
the common good and freedom do you see
as necessary to changing public
conversations
and politics around health in this
country
well i have to say i don't know who and
i'm going to say her uh
this person genia moore but i'm just
going to say this
man if you had an idea you got to share
it because i think that that's literally
what we
we spend our time thinking most about is
how can we make this
an issue that is everyone's issue um
and you know increasingly i mean there's
i guess like the ways that we've thought
about it is that
core to us is um
is as i shared it's um
and i think i'm reminded daily i mean
there's a deep urgency to this work
and it's urgent from some people more
than others but i feel like because i
see patients and then my lab is always
you know
um that it's this is a matter of
survival
right and so trying to think about the
right sorts
of questions to expand this to include
others
um i think it's important it also i
think is
um should i say this
it's not a surprise but it also uh
um it's not a surprise i also
uh it i think it slightly loathsome too
um that there's increased interest in
thinking about
criminal justice policies given the
opioid epidemic
and a you know focus now that
white communities rural communities are
interested these are places of
urgent intervention it's also a place
where we feel like well then we just
have to be strategic about it
and so i think our lab really thinks
hard about how it is that we can broaden
the conversation
include more people we've been at
increasingly some of the research that
you'll come you'll see coming out our
lab is focused on families so
we've really um there's beautiful work
done by chris wildeman's team
in cornell where he finally created a
national estimate of how many people
have have a family member that's been
exposed to incarceration right and so
in this country i don't know if you all
have seen it but it's almost half
right and then among black black
communities it's even higher
um and so yeah we've done a study using
the data fam hiss i think he's publicly
shared it so
um and we've embedded in their measures
of well-being and what we found was that
um you know pretty profound but even if
you had an extended
family member that's incarcerated a
cousin a godparent whatever
um your well-being is worse than those
that have never had
a person with a history incarceration
and this well-being measure that we use
translates to life expectancy and so i
mean i think that a lot of it is just
thinking about the other stakeholders
that are impacted family members
um one of our team members is now again
within the context of covid
starting to think about kind of
correctional officers so
i recently learned that their me i don't
know if this
should be quoted because i don't know
this to be a true fact but i heard
that uh mean life expectancy is 66
so it's crazy low and i think it's
because they work
in toxic stressful environments you know
the same toxicity that our patients feel
they feel too and it's a way of also
bringing in other people into the
conversation covett is doing that for us
so it's trying to bring into the
conversation other people
um who haven't always been in the
conversation
of how it is that we decarcerate and so
we're really trying to work
on that and you know where we where
we're best is
is um in both doing the research and
then trying to think about
uh yeah more legal avenues now
of of trying to expand that conversation
um emily i was also wondering there was
another question that came
up and i i i didn't ask initially but i
want to ask
has somebody asked the question and it
had to do with i'm not sure if there was
um
something behind the question but they
were they wanted to know specifically
about
asthma and i'm not quite sure but they
it may have been some logic in it that i
just
because i think you were talking about a
lot of the things that
um incarcerated people were suffering
and it may be an environmental question
but
there's a question that asks um how many
i'm seeing if i can find it but how many
people what's the what's the
how are there a lot of people who are
incarcerated who are suffering from
asthma
yeah um it is a great question and let
me just see if i can just
pull up um so it's a great question
so what i i can say about it right off
the cuff
is that people that are incarcerated
have higher rates
of asthma compared to the general
population
in fact they have higher rates of
hypertension they have higher rates
of heart disease uh and then certainly
of hepatitis c so people that have been
incarcerated have kind of
disproportionately higher rates
and then um look at this i'm going to
just share the screen so yeah
here we go
yeah she can y'all see that um
no i don't see it's coming now there we
go there we go
so um and these are data that are taken
you know again um from a bureau of
justice statistics survey
um so people that are in prison that you
know i just realized i
never kind of defined this though this
might be just real basic for you guys
but you know jails and prisons are
different so jails has those
uh people that are awaiting adjudication
of crimes or um
uh serving sentences of less than a year
and then prisons house those that are
have been sentenced typically for
uh um sentences longer than a year
and so these data come from the bureau
of justice statistics um
and so what you can see here last row
here asthma
is um that it's at 14.9
in the prison population compared to the
general population at 10.2 and the jail
population is 20.1 compared to 11.4
and uh these are data from 20
11 to 20 to 12 but are probably
uh you know they'd be the same here it's
disproportionately higher
and as is the case for many chronic
conditions um
cervical cancer it goes on and on
and um we are running close to time so
i'm going to ask the final question and
the question is what can
what what and this is a big question um
but i think it's an important question
and what people
and one of my students are out one that
my students are always asking me
is what what can we do right what can we
do to support this work
um and what's at stake um if we don't
in in some ways right so in some ways
i'm just it's that kind
i feel like you've presented us with um
what feels like a call to action
when when i see the photos and i hear
how you talk about them i'm like okay
we we've got it we got to move on this
um
and so us in the community of
african-american studies
what can we do to support this work well
i
you know it's interesting to say there's
you know i only recently started reading
uh history of the freedmen's bureau
you know and um and it's in that reading
that i realized
uh you know it's a it's
a deeply challenged history right it's
the first it was the first if i'm
understanding national health system
in our country um and was grossly
underfunded
and has so many deep parallels because
it was essentially a second class you
know healthcare system
for certain sorts of people you know uh
former slaves right so and it's similar
like we've constructed
a whole other operating health system
that is totally out of view that's
financed by our collective dollars
that we've just thrown it away and it
has differential impacts across kind of
our communities
but it's a place that i think really
requires deep
inquiry now what i'm interested in
seeing are kind of how house
how you know like um how uh
doctors health allied professionals like
how
are we complicit in that bringing out
that history
where are places um you know
i mean i just haven't seen uh and again
i
i just doubted myself which is like i've
just newly started reading about the
freeman's bureau so you know you hear
what i'm saying so maybe that there's a
ton
out there but when we've you know turned
to our colleagues within um
history and um legal scholars and then
even miriam rich who's
at the history of medicine within you
there isn't
a lot as far as she can tell and she you
know she's a scholar mass incarceration
in the intersections of health
of how physicians are complicit or
haven't been how they've been
revolutionary
we need narratives that help kind of
make this our own
issue and so i i kind of would turn it
to you which is that
i think the work that you do is
illuminating it gives us
um a grounding for what is possible what
had been possible what's deeply flawed
it also makes us realize like in turning
to a historical perspective
this stuff isn't new i mean it just
doesn't now
we just have you know it's like kind of
popped up again
and and for me you know like i think
especially for generations of new med
students they think oh my gosh this is
the first time in its own
and we just have to i i think that there
are also going to be stories out there
within history of solutions of radical
uprisings
of ways that physician days that health
systems you know or
you know yeah more grassroots health
systems have come up
to fight this and to me those stories
have to be told for us to kind of
um yeah to kind of
embrace a fuller and richer and create a
more uh
honest narrative of who we are
how we are as health communities and how
we've really
kind of have never uh cared for
um black people in this country i mean
um i
i just invite you guys to step foot into
prisons and jails i mean
that to me is like i i feel like the
first time i did it
i just couldn't turn back um
it's and then i've been to prison jails
all over now
uh the world and so i have to say
it it doesn't matter it's just so deeply
you know we've created a system that
really um i don't know
the last patient i saw come home from
prison was 75 spent 40 years inside
i mean that just can't be this you know
40 years inside drink of it so
um i guess that that's what i would say
is
there's a lot to be done you know and i
i like
doctors are real pragmatic i guess so
like i'm like well there's stuff you
could do now later but i mean i think
like
for me i mean and then we welcome kind
of you know come over to our side
of the campus there's a lot going on
here
and uh we have you know i look at
crystal uh
but you know we've developed and and
have growing relationships certainly uh
with um folks on the fas side but you
know our strongest roots right now at
the law school but would love
uh real partnerships across
um yale because i i do think like
especially just thinking about
who is coming next up in your endeavors
uh series i mean
this is a place where i think uh yell
has many many assets to offer
um how we kind of reimagine and reshape
conversations around
what a decarcerated system looks like
thank you
i think that is a powerful note um to
end on an
amazing invitation particularly to our
graduate students who are doing
creative and imaginative work on you
know
policing on the environment and how
um you know the cultural state has
impacted black lives
um and that i know that some of them
after today will be drawn
to the center and i will encourage them
and
and my colleagues um to
engage in in a conversation with you and
your work
so again thank you for sharing this with
us we learned so much i'm going to ask
people to unmute in
this moment before you go off and we're
going to do a
clap that you can actually hear right
instead of
so if people will unmute that would be
great
um thank you so much